at this point calling artifact that
daddy game would be insulting to dead
games DOTA allstars CS 1.6 and brood war
are dead games but there are thousands
of people who play them every day it is
a good day to die
artifact is beyond dead destroy an enemy
artifact but artifact is already dead in
just a few months its player basis
dwindles from tens of thousands of
people to only a few hundred large
defects dead game that's what happened
as of June 2019 at any given time there
are about a hundred and thirty people
playing artifact there are more people
playing football manager 2010 Call of
Duty ghosts and soccer a clicker right
now than artifact fact is garbage it is
impossible to overstate how humiliating
it is for a game that was made by mouth
the makers of steam counter-strike
half-life and plenty more hits to fail
like this it's the biggest streaming the
[ __ ] artifact section 6 viewers is
this guy artifact isn't just valves
greatest failure it's their only failure
but it wasn't supposed to be I mean they
can't release it like this artifact was
supposed to change everything
oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] J it had something for
everyone
a welcome reduction in RNG for people
who played hearthstone it was arguably
even more complicated than magic and it
really seemed like it had the legs to be
the dota community's newest side piece
do I think there will be another game
that will hold my attention I know that
did all these years yes there is a
certain game called artifacts and then
in the wake of one perfect storm how
came crashing them now in order to
understand why artifact failed we have
to go all the way back to the
International 2017 where it was first
revealed I have a special announcement
to make
now it's not half-life 3 for what it's
worth it's not a new hero but valve
has a new game coming soon you're not
giving me the appropriate reaction that
deserves and instead of being greeted by
cheers old invok'd was a outside of
disappointment
artifacts public life began with the
first of its many problems valve was
pitching it to a community that just
didn't care the good news is that valve
has announced a brand new game the first
and what feels like eons the bad news is
that it's a game that most people didn't
really ask for valve could have
announced that they'd finally figured
out how to fix the lag on monkey kings
alt and received a standing ovation
instead they pulled a roomful of dota
fiends that their explosive MOBA was
being turned into a card game it is
fully understandable to be disappointed
when their new game turns out to be
their own version of hearthstone but
then valve announced that Richard
Garfield would be heading up artifacts
development the legend himself ladies
and germs - Richard Garfield man the
creator of everything you've ever loved
one of the original creators of Magic
the Gathering Garfield has a proven
record when it comes to turning out
masterpieces hearthstone was huge at the
time and in order to beat it the hell
brought in one of the creators of their
genre I really enjoyed the electronic
card games that had come out but I felt
like they didn't capture the epic of
quality you sometimes got in paper card
games and and so I've talked to valve
about about that gave us ideas for
mechanics that you could use to do that
and and three years later this is where
we are he's always been regarded as a
bona fide genius with a PhD in
combinatorial mathematics and artifact
was being touted as his most
sophisticated project and yet I would
say the the first piece of advice I give
to somebody coming to this from other
card games is that they can't really
think of it as a card game they're used
to in the in that the complexity of the
game the the strategic state is much
broader than they're used to so I
usually tell them to think of it as like
a MOBA or a realtime strategy game but
put set on cards over the course of the
next year artifacts clout went up
significantly valve put the game into a
highly exclusive closed beta and over
time how does that build up something of
a mystique well from all if I got
like this amazing game and I will
definitely give it a try
they even announce that artifact would
have its own 1 million dollar tournament
which was groundbreaking by card game
standards so we are we do you think
tournaments inspect a shanaar going to
be super important we're going to start
off by having a similar to the original
international that we did for debtor
there's going to be a million dollar
tournament by the time gaben made his
next TI appearance it was clear that
even the dota community's opinion on
artifact to change if she's going to
ticket to your couch you get a free copy
of artifact I've been trying really had
a guy do you think but yeah no noise
bothering me did you just use a loser
interview to ask for an artifact key and
then in November 2018
artifact was released to the world but
it wasn't the launch that Valve wanted
it became clear pretty quickly that the
game had problems problems that people
would have found out about beforehand if
only the game had an open beta first of
all the games $20 price tag and
so-called open economy really frustrated
some players economy is a huge problem I
didn't I'm concerned about it personally
now there's nothing wrong with having an
open economy in theory the issue is that
Valve was selling it on a digital
marketplace and the people that Valve
was trying to poach away from
hearthstone well if they were used to a
free-to-play model one where they could
grind cards for free and then had the
option of paying for packs those people
felt kind of cheated by artifact if you
don't get three wins and expert
constructed or phantom draft you don't
get a ticket back so if you lose all
your tickets the only way you get
tickets is to buy it there should be
another way to earn tickets to get you
into expert play I like a lot of things
about the game but the economy is is
pretty expensive for a lot of people but
one of the most hotly contested issues
about artifact was its design some
people felt like it was way too RNG
heavy while others thought it wasn't RNG
heavy enough you know what really bugs
me is when people are saying there's no
RNG in the game or like yeah the RG is
all controlled play around all the ROG
game is it orangey FS it's just object
it objectively is I have a problem with
the game at the moment in that regard
that I don't see a clear direction what
we want to make with the game do we want
to make it fun a little bit more orangey
heavy or do we want to make it like
super competitive with orangey it
doesn't make sense with most people
thought it was a beautifully designed
but that hardly mattered because the
launch was handled so poorly isn't this
game that already know yeah
KYNA I don't know but it's a fun game
okay it's a the game is actually good
the moment you stop adding value to
valve which is usually the moment you
ship a piece of software they don't care
after artifacts been out do you how many
times valve employees from the artifact
team have answered any questions of mine
big ol [ __ ] zero nun the final nail in
the coffin was at Magic the Gathering
arena the client that finally brought
magic to the masses launched in fall
2018 by January 2019 the damage had been
done
artifact speak concurrent player count
had dropped from an already
underwhelming 46,000 to just six
thousand dollars defect good game that's
what happened adding fuel to some
critics fire Garfield was terminated by
valve amidst all this mess now Garfield
rarely stays on with a design team after
he's launched a game but the optics
weren't great the worst part though was
watching all these streamers who went
all in on artifact flounder as they
realized they've gotten on a sinking
ship I don't really know what I'm gonna
do maybe hey maybe I should just bail
maybe everyone else is just smarter than
me and I'm just an idiot frozen still
playing this game and then in May 2019
valve released a statement acknowledging
that artifact had some deep-rooted
problems and they be going back to
square one to try to fix them it even
looks like a valve is gonna try to
enlist the artifact community for help
if there's anybody left in the artifact
community I mean I can tell you right
now that there's there's a lot of people
that think that our de fact is like
something that they've completely
abandoned and will never update I can
tell you right now is that they are
working on updating it this is something
that I have actually seen like I visited
valve literally a week ago the thing is
at this point it doesn't seem like it's
even possible to resurrect artifact the
reason why artifact failed is because
artifact just wasn't a fun game
the game subreddit has already devolved
into a wasteland of sadness spite and
admittedly top-tier memes while the
games twitch page was recently home to
illegal streams of anime porn and
Avengers endgame so could artifact have
been all the things that was supposed to
be the hearthstone killer the half-life
2 of card games valves greatest
moneymaker in a history maybe but
unfortunately until valve figures out a
way to bring artifact back from the dead
it'll go down in history as not only one
of their greatest failures but also one
of the greatest games that never was
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]